Well,
oftentimes business education today,
and I see it all the time,
kids come out of college,
the best colleges,
wharton and Harvard and Stanford and
some of the great business schools and
they'll come out and they won't have
practical experience is too many case
studies that aren't practical.
You know,
we ask,
uh,
kids that are 16 to 18 years old to make
$100,000 debt decisions when they go off
to university and they're not prepared
for that.
They don't know what they're getting
themselves into.
They just assume,
okay,
I'm going to pay for years of education
to 25,000 a pop and when I come out the
other side,
somehow we'll be able to pay it back.
That's not how life works anymore.
There's no need even to have a college
degree at all or even high school.
I mean,
if somebody graduated from a great
university that maybe in indy,
that may be an indication that they will
be capable of great things,
but it's not necessarily the case.
You know,
if you look at say people like Bill
Gates or Larry Ellison,
Steve Jobs,
these guys didn't graduate from college,
but if you had a chance to hire them,
of course I would be a good idea.
Um,
I think having the flexibility to
explore a lot of different things which
you can do when you're in college,
which is one of the amazing things about
being in college is you can work on all
these hobbies and encode a lot of stuff
and try a lot of different things.
It's this amazing flexibility that I
think most people take for granted and
once you decide,
okay,
I'm going to start a company,
I'm going to do it with someone else,
you immediately now need to convince
someone else if you want to change your
mind on something.
And I think people really undervalue the
option value and flexibility.
I think explore what you want to do
before committing is really like the key
thing and keep yourself flexible and no,
I think that that's agreed.
Yeah.
I mean it's actually kind of funny.
I like if you're like,
what is education?
Like you're basically downloading data
and algorithms into your brain and it's,
it's,
it's actually amazingly bad in
conventional education because like it
shouldn't be like this huge tour
almost standing up there kind of
lecturing at people and they've done the
same lecturer or 20 years in a row and
are very excited about it and in fact I
think a lot of things that people learn
it probably there's no point in learning
because they never used them in the
future because a lot of kids are in
school.
Kind of puzzled as to why they're there.
The people who are doing the work that
we care about are figuring out what to
do next,
not following the person who told them
what to do next.
And the problem with most colleges is
they are high school,
but with more binge drinking.
The entire purpose of a university is to
give you a foundation to fail.
Not a foundation to get an a.
and if you graduated from college,
straight a's,
you have to do some serious soul
searching as to why you chose to spend
your time doing that.
A student's work for the students.
The C students run the businesses and
that these students dedicate the
buildings.
It's like the newspaper
industry ripe more printing presses,
more big buildings,
right?
It makes us look grander.
We have brains that we're putting them
out there.
There's there's a point of diminishing
returns in terms of what it's worth for
a college education and how much debt
you're willing to saddle yourself with.
A lot of people fall.
A lot of people have follow is
generally.
If not,
we'd have problems.
We have too many entrepreneurs.
We have so many successful people.
Look how many people go into business
classes and everything you needed was in
that actual business class.
In that book,
it'd be too many successful business
people.
Right?
How many people graduate?
Matter of fact,
the professor wouldn't have the time to
sit there and teach you that knows this
book them near verbatim,
page by page.
He knows,
right?
Because he'd be an entrepreneur.
He too busy.
I'm too.
I'm doing way too much right now because
I got the palm trees and then we do it.
We sell it so much stuff that I'm doing
that I ain't quite got time to teach
them about class right now because I'm
winning
and so when you walk into a board room
with a bunch of guys in suits who all
went to college,
you're fine.
Yeah,
I mean because they read a bunch of
words.
I've lived a bunch of life.
That's true.
They're more degree,
doesn't intimidate you.
It kinda evens is out whether they know
it and not get that self esteem from
seriously.
I mean most mom first and foremost,
but then just living life like you know,
being in real situations and happened to
be a person of high integrity and
honesty and you know,
you never embarrassed yourself.
Of course not.
You'd ever walked in and said,
hi,
everybody thinks I'm ignorant here.
I'm stupid.
I don't feel ignorant right now.
I don't.
I felt like I came up in this situation
or a time,
you know,
where I wasn't afforded certain
opportunities and if afforded
opportunities I could be oprah,
could be a Bill Gates,
I could be Warren Buffet.
In my experience in business,
there is very little difference.
If any,
between a very high price business
education and what's available a lot for
a lot less money.
I went to the University of Nebraska at
Lincoln.
I last year in college.
I went to wharton for a couple years
before that.
Uh,
I learned just as much as university
Nebraska as I did at wharton at indeed a
big product in the right direction.
But an awful lot of it is,
is,
is self.
The self taught it isn't necessary to
pay 30 or $35,000 a year.
I go to some big name school to get the
education at all.
I mean,
if you're going to learn accounting,
if you're going to,
which is the probably the most important
course you'd taken business,
you're gonna learn to count.
You can learn accounting absolutely as
well in my view,
going to you all.
It was going to Harvard.
I mean,
I,
I see,
uh,
I would,
I bet on that.
And uh,
so I wouldn't run up huge bells
and education is very good at training
people to do the same things that we've
done over and over again.
And I think there's always a question
what the nature of the educational good
is.
A,
you can say it's a,
it's an investment.
Good.
We're investing in the future.
You can say it's a consumption good.
Like college is a four year party,
you know,
I think most of the parents and students
think of it actually is an insurance
policy where you're buying this really
ever more expensive insurance so that
the students don't fall through the
really big cracks in our society.
And we should be asking some big
questions why the insurance costs are
going up and up like that.
And if you were the president of Harvard
or Stanford,
if you want it to get,
um,
a lynch mob of students,
alumni,
faculty to come after you and try to
lynch you,
what you should say is something like
this.
You know,
we,
we live in this much larger,
more global world.
We offer a great education to everybody
and so we're going to double or triple
our enrollment over the next 15 to 20
years.
And people would,
they'd all be furious because the value
of the degrees comes from this massive
exclusion.
Um,
and,
and what you're really running is
something like a studio 54 nightclub.
I hate it.
I hated school.
I hated school generally,
right?
Because it was this instruction
following thing.
Now I bet you it's probably also because
I wasn't good at it and some people are
like,
I've got a great conceptual memory and a
terrible rote memory.
So if I have a story I could tell you
year by year kind of what happened,
um,
within a story,
within a context a.
But if I was to go into,
you know,
like a memory based learning,
it's terrible.
I have a terrible rote memory.
Ego Barrier is the worst thing.
And if we were raised differently,
just imagine in the schools at all along
that people will always say everybody
makes mistakes.
Everybody has weaknesses.
The key is really to understand what
your mistakes and weaknesses are so that
you can learn from them.
Right?
I think punishment is,
is it is a terrible concept.
Punishment means that you made a mistake
and you're being punished.
I think instead of punishment,
every time somebody makes a mistake,
you just say,
the only thing that you need to do to
get out of your punishment is first
think what kind of mistake was that?
So if I'm in this situation that's like
that again,
how would I do deal with it differently
not to make that mistake?
So that learning should come from the
mistake,
not punishment,
because you're teaching people not to
make mistakes.
We're,
whereas where the learning comes from,
not the appreciation that if you keep
doing this over and over again,
you're going to keep encountering the
same outcomes.
You know,
it's an extremely,
a corrupt system.
We have at this point,
there is,
we have an education bubble in the US.
We have a trillion dollars of student
debt to a first approximation.
This has gone to pay for a trillion
dollars worth of lies about the value of
the education people have received.
Um,
and um,
and I,
it's not at all obvious yet though,
what's going to,
what's going to replace this or how it's
going to change.
Um,
my um,
you know,
the,
uh,
you know,
the,
and I'm somewhat skeptical that it will
be replaced by any sort of single
unitary system and I have this
fellowship for a young people to start
companies and it's not,
my claim is not that everybody should do
this.
I don't think everyone should become an
entrepreneur.
And I think,
I think there is no one size fits all.
I think so.
I think the future will be much more
heterogeneous,
much more diverse in terms of what
people do.
Um,
and uh,
what's,
what's really anomalous is the sort of
unitary tracking where you have to go to
an elite college,
you go to Yale or you go to jail,
there's nothing else you can do,
you know.
Um,
and so the,
the,
uh,
I think the universities are perhaps in
perhaps in the same place as the
Catholic Church was in 1,514.
If we go back 500 years where,
uh,
you have sort of a monolithic way,
you this universal way of a body of
knowledge of teaching things.
The difference between the Yale and the
Harvard political science faculties are
probably no greater than the differences
between the Dominicans and the
Franciscans.
We've all kinds of small debates within
this context.
Um,
uh,
we are,
we have a system of indulgences that's
costing more and more to support this
priestly or professorial class of
people.
We are told that,
uh,
it's the only way to salvation.
You must get a diploma to be saved.
If you do not get a diploma,
then you will go to hell.
Um,
and I think,
um,
and I think the,
uh,
I think the,
the,
the message that I have that's like the
16th century reformers,
that's a somewhat troubling message is
that you have to work out your salvation
on your own.
You have to save yourself.
And,
uh,
and,
and that's,
that's,
I think,
I believe that is the truth.
But it's a,
it's,
it's somewhat uncomfortable with.